let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right well the cdc has uh released
its thanksgiving guidelines
i will be disregarding all of their
thanksgiving guidelines just as i've
disregarded
everything else they've said um but just
for fun
here they are from fox5ny here are the
guidelines
i'll read a few of these to you in case
in case you're wondering in case you in
case you want to
get the cdc's approval like you're
planning your thanksgiving
dinner and celebration and you're
thinking what does a cdc think about
this
here's what they said limiting the
number of attendees as much as possible
and allowing people from home from
different
households to social distance at all at
all times is also encouraged
hosting the gathering outdoors rather
than indoors as much as possible and
requiring guests to wear
masks when they aren't eating or
drinking is also encouraged
if you're hosting an indoor gathering
the cdc says to increase ventilation as
much as possible
by opening windows and doors thanks for
that recommendation cdc i i never would
have thought to
open my windows if it's a little stuffy
inside i needed the cdc to tell me that
when it comes to food and drinks the cdc
says host should encourage guests to
bring food for themselves and members of
their household and to avoid
potluck style gatherings
okay so you're all bringing your own
meal and you're just sitting
down with glass partitions
with masks on lift the mask up
stuff the turkey wing in if you're
preparing or serving food for guests
that don't live in your household you
should wear a mask
guests are encouraged to have a plan for
storing their mask while eating and
drinking
um as always everyone is asked to wash
their hands with hope
soap and water for 20 seconds
again i needed the cdc to tell me that i
would never have thought
to wash my hands with soap and water
usually i use
um ginger ale to wash my hands
and so uh every time every time i see
this reminder from the cdc use soap and
water i think
oh yeah i forgot the second iteration of
cdc thanksgiving guidance also includes
recommendations for safe travel and
overnight stays
um and uh blah blah blah on and on
yeah this is this is something i just
will not be
paying attention to whatsoever um and
yet again this is this is the cdc
now at least at least it's the cdc here
it's a lot worse than like in a place
like california
where you've got the health department
taking all of these
guidelines and actually making it a a
matter of law
even though of course the department of
health doesn't have the authority to
just create
laws but um they're trying to do it and
they're trying to use the force of law
to force you to do it
so at least with the cdc it's just a
guideline which we don't have to listen
to
and um and i won't you know this is this
is one of the worst things
to come of the covet hysteria is just
the the paranoia and suspicion that
we're supposed to have
even towards our own families
like if you're if your aunt comes to
your thanksgiving
and she brought her green bean casserole
do you know you don't eat that it might
be infected with covid
number two um this from the daily wire
says the fallout from this summer's
riots which saw
businesses large and small looted and
burned to the ground continues to be
seen
as a new report from the new york times
shines a light on the insurance woes
faced by those whose livelihoods were
destroyed in the name of racial justice
it says the outlet reported while large
chains like walmart and best buy have
excellent insurance
many small businesses that have been
burned down since the riots lack similar
coverage and for them
there is no easy way to replace all that
they lost in kenosha
more than 35 small businesses were
completely destroyed and around 80 have
been damaged according to the city's
business association
almost all are locally owned and many
are underinsured or struggling to manage
now and the the report goes on with the
daily wire you can read it there but
i wanted to highlight that because this
is something you heard from the rioters
and from blm
the the excuse they gave is that uh
including that clip we played a few
times of the blm activist i think she
was in chicago
saying that looting is a form of
reparations and encouraging people to do
it and saying oh the businesses all have
insurance so you just take what you want
now these are people who don't
understand how insurance works it's not
just you
you have insurance you can you can take
whatever you want and magically
like you you could burn down their
business and because you have insurance
it will
magically you regenerate on its own
like the wolverine and x-men or
something that's regeneration power
suggests you
steal whatever you want you can steal
the tv and then the tv will will
re-materialize in its place
um that seems to be what they think but
that's not how insurance works
and also as it turns out of course a lot
of these businesses
don't have insurance or underinsured
and you know even even if they even if
they do have insurance that can cover
all of it of course
just this should go without saying that
doesn't
mean you can just go and take whatever
you want
like if if i'm if i'm sure that you have
really great car
insurance that doesn't mean i can just
ram into you on the highway
and say well you got car insurance what
are you what are you whining about you
got car insurance
number three this is a tough time for
the media because they can't quite
decide
if if now you know now that they've
declared buy it in the winner
they can't quite decide if they should
just pretend that kovit has gone away
and been cured
or if they should double down on the
fear porn in hopes that biden will
put us into a full lockdown again mask
mandates and everything else
so they're kind of trying to walk this
high wire act of propaganda where
they're they're sort of doing both and i
feel for them
because it's got to be difficult to
figure out exactly how
you want to lie to people but on the
fear porn side of things
there's this article from reuters
headline is
very scary headline listen to the
headline
one in five covet 19 patients develop
mental illness
within 90 days okay now
this makes it sound like covet is
causing some kind of neurological damage
making people go insane or something
when they have covered 19. that that's
what it sounds like when you see that
headline
and if you saw that headline you didn't
click on it you would just absorb that
impression that half-baked vague
impression
and bring it with you throughout your
your day and that's that's what you're
supposed to do that's the point
but then you click on it and here's what
it says many kova 19 survivors are
likely to be at a greater risk of
developing mental illness
according to psychiatrists after a large
study found 20 of those infected with
the chronovirus are diagnosed with a
psychiatric disorder within 90 days what
are the disorders though
anxiety depression and insomnia were the
most common
uh reported among recovered coven 19
patients in the study
anxiety depression and insomnia okay
so people with coronavirus a disease
that the media says will kill them
a disease that we're told you know we
had to shut down the country for
um when they have it they feel
anxious and depressed
wow amaze huge news amazing put this in
a headline you got it it's incredible
stuff
i can't believe that people who get sick
with a virus
that even donald trump calls the plague
which by the way i really wish you would
stop doing that
but crazy that the people with that
virus would have anxiety about it
totally unexpected hey you know i wonder
what kind of mental illness
have the lockdowns caused and the media
coverage
i bet there's a lot of anxiety and
depression out there from people who
never even got sick
now this is ridiculous but then you know
i i must admit
i say all this um admittedly as someone
who holds an extremely
heterodox view about anxiety and
depression
um i don't really agree that either of
those things are mental illnesses to
begin with
like i said i know it's heretical these
days you're not allowed to say this
i i actually think that anxiety in
particular
is a completely normal though not
enjoyable aspect of the human experience
even a defining aspect of the human
experience part of what makes us human
is that we can contemplate our own
existence
and feel despair or feel worried about
it feel anxious
which doesn't mean that despair and
anxiety are good or should be welcomed
but it does mean that it's not a disease
it's not a disorder
it's not a medical issue and it's a
perfect example of why
oh they they have they have depression
and anxiety
there's a very a very discernible reason
for that
sort of it a mental illness is absurd
it's just you're reacting in a pretty
normal way to your environment
now i think there are a lot of people
that have way too much anxiety about the
chronovirus because of all the fear porn
that the media puts out but still it's a
it's a normal and predictable reaction
to your environment
and in general even even without even
without chronovirus
the fact is that there's there's a lot
in the world that could make someone
feel despair make them feel anxious make
them feel anxiety
again not saying you should feel it not
saying if you do feel you should just
embrace it and live with it
um but it's not it's not disordered it's
not diseased
but of course what the what the
pharmaceutical industry has done is
they've just decided
they've taken these normal aspects of
the human experience
and they've drawn completely arbitrary
lines and said
um you know it's okay to feel this much
despair like here's the despair line
and you can feel the spare up to that
line but if you feel it over that line
now it's a disease and we're going to
medicate it
who who says who where did you come up
with this
who told you where the line is
all right um as we have covered leftists
have been busy making lists recently
lists of all the heretics who have
been insufficiently loyal to leftist
orthodoxy especially anyone who's
expressed support for trump
and they seem to have gotten on the list
kick and are going wild with it right
now
uh here's a list that was on cnn
yesterday this woman whoever she is i'm
not sure who is
she has a list of gop senators who have
not congratulated joe biden
and it's it's like all of them except
for i guess mitt romney so it's pretty
much all that you
might be one or two others of
congratulations so i look at this and i
can pretty much guarantee you
that this lady has a similar list at her
house probably up on her fridge
of every acquaintance who didn't wish
her a happy birthday
i'd like to see a segment on that
subject maybe cnn could do a segment
about all the people who didn't wish
this woman a happy birthday or maybe
extended family members who still
haven't sent her
a wedding gift you know even though her
wedding was three years ago
these list list makers they just they
can't help themselves
finally i want to play this for you uh
simply because it is to my mind the most
important piece of reporting
that msnbc has ever done um
this was really hard-hitting stuff and i
just thought it was
a really really important piece of
reporting here here it is take a look
nbc's ken delanian has some new
reporting on something that we talked
about
at the top of the hour how the trump
administration
is handling the transition with the
incoming biden team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ]
okay uh i think we lost think we lost
ken for a sec
i think the explanation that he gave for
that is that he was having
um technical difficulties and didn't
realize he was on camera
and so that's why that happened but the
way that i read it
at least what i would like to think is
that he got some
he's reacting to like some news via text
message
or maybe he was trying to order chicken
wings by doordash
but the place was outside of the the
delivery zone
and i admit i have reacted in a similar
way in
similar situations many many times just
not usually on on
camera though that's the only difference
so but that is
maybe msnbc's best moment i think it's
only right for us to take a moment and
recognize it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content